hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
we're talking about technical interviews
today so today we're going to talk again
about technical interviews i've talked
about technical interviews before on my
channel how many times have i talked
about it i'm not sure but at least once
or twice but it is such an important
part of the software engineering
interview process so
it is worth talking about it again and
again and again and again and again and
yet and again and again and again for
those of you who don't know the
technical interview is a standard part
of the three-part interview process that
most tech companies use to hire software
engineers like i've never not done a
technical interview for any of the jobs
that i've had there's always been at
least one technical interview part for
the interview process and yes i know
that you probably know that because
you're probably like a college student
studying computer science or something
similar or you're trying to break into
the industry with a career change when
you went to a coding bootcamp so you
know data structures and algorithms is a
very important part of the technical
interview process and i know you know
that because you probably use tools like
lead code or the cracking the coding
interview book and those are all great
tools but today i am here to talk about
what most people get wrong about the
technical interview by the way i did
make a video about how to study for
these interviews a very very long time
ago i might even remake the video
because it was so long ago but you can
find that right here so yes there is
something that a lot of people get wrong
about the technical interview it's not
that you don't know your data structures
enough and it's not that you didn't
study your time complexities enough
either it's also not that you didn't
study your algorithms it's the
behavioral side of interviews aka the
behavioral assessment that happens
during the technical portion of the
interview today we're going to talk
about that because i was a software
engineer for at least six years
professionally more if you count
internships and stuff like that and i've
been able to talk to a bunch of
different people about the technical
interview specifically this time i got
to talk to sophie who is the ceo of
formation her and her team coach people
to become the best software engineers
they can which you know big part of that
is the interview process so i had to
meet her and talk to her and pick her
brain about this whole thing about
behavioral parts of the technical
interview also thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring today's video
you can learn more about them and why
they're a great source to study for your
technical interviews at the very end of
the video so stick around okay so you
might be thinking hold up when you go
but i thought in a technical interview
the first thing that you're supposed to
do is code right they're there to assess
you on your coding skills so you should
maximize the time that you're spent
coding honestly that's actually not the
right thing to do at all
one of the first mistakes that i see
people make is start to code right away
that's pretty much never never the right
first step in
like solving a problem i sometimes use
this like analogy of imagine that you
like hired a contractor to come and
build a new deck in your backyard or
something and they come in and literally
30 seconds into it they're like tearing
things apart without having asked you
for like dimensions or like doing like a
landscape like safety survey to make
sure you have the right support
structures you're just like not trusting
this engineer right and so
um the very first thing when approaching
a new problem is exploring the bounds of
the problem by like asking a bunch of
questions i really really really like
that analogy that sophie used about
contractors and creating and fixing
stuff because that is literally how it's
like so as a fix before you jump
straight into coding start with
pseudocode that way you can work through
your logic and your solution without
getting bogged down in the details of if
else statements and syntax and apis and
functions and stuff like that because
the most important part of the technical
interview is to see how you think and if
you can solve a problem not about
whether you can like code super duper
well like at the end of the day software
engineering is about problem solving and
so before getting bogged down in the
details of coding literally just get
your logic right this also allows your
interviewer to step in in case your
logic is wrong because when you start
with pseudocode you can check in with
your interview and be like yo am i on
the right path does it sound good is
there anything that i'm missing and they
can kind of course correct and lead you
towards the right solution also the
right solution is also subjective
because there's not always a one right
solution there's maybe multiple right
solutions but a right solution and now
you might be thinking all right then may
you go so maybe we don't spend all of
our time coding but the thing that
they're gonna assess you on at the end
of the day for whether they're gonna
give you a job is the code itself right
no
no that's not the case because here's
the thing if you can't explain your
solution then how do they know if you
know how to code because here's the
thing you could be reciting a solution
from memory you know but software
engineering is about encountering
problems and solving those problems most
of which you've never seen before with
the similar conditions and constraints
and stuff the next kind of behavioral
thing that i would say to focus on is
the explanation of your approach i see a
lot of people one not explaining it at
all
so it's missing or explaining it way too
much like going into completely
unnecessary detail and going on for
minutes and minutes and minutes on how
how the solution works sophie touches on
a really important point here too that
it's like it seems like it's easy to
explain your solution to approach but
it's actually not it's it really
requires some skill to do that but for
anybody who wants to excel in the
industry have a long-term career work at
really great companies with really great
people on really great teams it's
something that you're really going to
want to practice ideally you're going to
want to be able to explain that solution
in a relatively concise way like one way
that i benchmark whether i can really
explain things or not is if i can
explain them in
plain spoken terms like if i were to
explain this concept or solution to
someone who doesn't even know how to
code doesn't know the technology will
they get it obviously in practice it
doesn't quite work this way but it's
also really easy to tell when a
candidate is like bsing their way
through things and telling just like
buzzwords after buzz words because you
can kind of tell after a while they
don't really know what they're saying
but yes all this thing of like
explaining your thought process is
definitely easier said than done but
there are ways to practice you can
practice by pulling up like a practice
problem or something and then literally
record yourself working through the
problem and then also giving the
solution so literally just like set up a
camera somewhere
and talk to the camera and then watch it
over and see if it makes sense and when
you are watching it over just kind of
like give yourself feedback on things
like are your word choices succinct are
you able to follow your like thought
pattern from step to step are you asking
enough questions about the problem are
you making the right assumptions are you
being clear about what your assumptions
are when you're working through the
problem are you getting stuck too long
on any one thing are you not getting
stuck long enough on something it's no
doubt a hard skill but it is something
that you can absolutely get better at
with consistent effort
interesting
interesting i'd never thought about it
that way i just always thought the
technical interviews were there to like
just grade you on your solution and your
thought process not exactly technical
interviewers more often than not are
going to be the people that you work
with and when it comes to actually
working together like imagining yourself
actually being co-workers no one's gonna
have the right solution like you're kind
of gonna have to figure it out together
the role of the interviewer in an
interview
is
to essentially
come prepared with a prompt
and
witness you as the engineer in the room
do your work again i love how sophie put
this together about just like an
engineer is there to witness your
problem solving like that word is so key
because
yes it kind of can seem like they're
trying to grade you and at the end of
the day they are they're going to
critique you on all of that but
you as a candidate really the best way
you can think about it is literally
someone's just there to watch you and
guide you through problem solving
because when it comes to actually
working that's what it's going to be
about so in the technical interview
itself one fix with all of this is to
ask questions about direction to your
interviewer like imagine that they're a
collaborator except maybe they know one
or two more pointers than you so confirm
that you're going towards the right
direction so say things like based on
abc i'm thinking of going towards xyz
and implementing it this way like what
do you think or you can also ask things
like is it safe to assume that
def is going to always be true this is a
totally harmless thing to do so long as
you're not asking your interviewer
you're like yo interviewer throw me a
bone like tell me what to do next or
like hey give me the solution don't do
that that's
that like that's no like your interview
is not your teacher they're your
collaborator but asking questions
confirming where you're going make sure
that you're focused and you're on the
right track and it gives the interviewer
an inside view into how you're thinking
which again they are there to witness
you and get a window into how you think
and approach a problem to begin with
otherwise don't you think that a lot of
these technical interviews would be like
here's a code snippet solve it and send
it back to us whenever you want which is
the case sometimes but hardly like is it
an actually really great way to figure
out who's going to be a good engineer on
your team and who's not okay
but like why isn't the technical side
important like why do we need technical
interviews then because software
engineers are hired to code right so
isn't that the whole reason yes but
imagine working with an engineer who
never thinks their solution and hashily
creates code thus creating mountains of
spaghetti code can't produce their own
unique code and can't solve unique
problems and or can't explain their
solutions on what they wrote like that
would suck right so yes that's the kind
of engineer that you want to avoid
becoming and thus is the type of
engineer that companies want to avoid
hiring granted the most important factor
of technical interviews is to know
whether you're able to solve problems
and if you know your stuff but the
behavioral side of technical interviews
has a ton of weight to it more than you
might think when when things get really
contentious
on whether we we accept someone or not
it is always the behavioral side that
makes the call because really the thing
that most reveals who you are and shows
your employer how you tick is going to
be shown in the behavioral side of the
interview this is where they're going to
really understand the value that you add
to your team by seeing how you work like
do you produce code that's easy to
reason about do you think about how
other people are going to use the code
other than yourself are you able to
explain and teach concepts that you know
to make people on your team better
engineers and are you just like a
respectful and kind collaborator that
people like working with so yeah
technical interviews are definitely the
most stressful and hardest part of the
interview process and yes at the end of
the day it's the interview that's going
to suss out your technical skill so you
definitely do need to study up on data
structures and algorithms and systems
design questions but just remember that
they're also really assessing you on
other stuff too technical interviews in
fact are the closest simulation they'll
get to would it be like to actually work
with you so when you're studying for
these interviews yes use elite code
cracking the coding interview brilliant
or whatever resources are out there to
study but i really highly recommend you
to try recording yourself solving these
problems studying with a friend or
partner or someone close to you
do like a mock interview or something
who can give you constructive feedback
on how to make the behavioral side of
your interview better and in order to
get good feedback think about the kind
of engineer that you want to be the kind
of problem solver that you want to be
and the kind of teammate that you want
to be once you have those answers to
that you'll get good feedback and you'll
be able to show off all of that in the
interview and ultimately that's what
companies want to see from you the fact
that you can solve technical problems in
a very nice collaborative kind
way that actually solves problems well
where you can explain your solution if
that wasn't clear thank you so much to
sophie from formation.dev for being a
part of this video and sharing your
insight i'll leave her link in the
description box down below and also
thank you so much to brilliant for
sponsoring this video so if you have
heard me talk about brilliant before
then you know that it's a platform
dedicated to active problem solving
because i am a strong believer that in
order to really truly learn something
you can't just be watching it or reading
about it you have to actually be doing
it and brilliant's platform is perfect
for this because all of their courses
are super interactive and allow you to
really engage with the material
brilliant has recently upped their
interactivity on their platform to a
brand new level so you're really going
to benefit from learning and reinforcing
and studying up on things like
algorithms on brilliant because you know
the thing about studying for technical
interviews is that you can't just read
through problems you have to actually
like go and do it and engage with it and
write pseudocode and understand how
things work you can take the courses on
brilliant at your own pace so if you'd
like to try out brilliant for free and
get 20 off a year of stem learning then
click the link in the description box
down below or visit brilliant.org
hellomyuco thank you so much for
watching and maybe share this with
someone who's like going through the
technical interview process right now i
know it's a lot of different stuff to
balance but trust me if you get this
right and you are really good at
technical interviews both the really
technical coding part and the behavioral
part then you're gonna do well by the
way if you have any questions about
technical interviewing that you want me
to answer then i'm gonna reply to every
comment that's on my exclusive bonus
content that i put out just for members
uh there's gonna be one paired with this
video and so you can become a member for
as low as 99 cents a month get access to
exclusive perks and ask your question
there make sure to subscribe to my
channel for more content about tech
career and life for me and i'll see you
next time bye